l'été de melgven c'est probablement
l'été du camping des sports nautiques et
du vélo pas étonnant parce que les
canadiens qui ont dû faire une croix sur
leurs projets de voyage avait
soudainement des économies à consacrer à
l'achat d'équipements sportifs et
récréatifs et c'est un phénomène qui est
mondial partout sur la planète les
fabricants de vélos ont été complètement
dévalisés on va en parler avec martin le
sauteur et les pdg d'argon 18 c'est une
entreprise québécoise de vélo bonjour
monsieur l'auteur
bonjour quand on explique ce à cet
engouement mondial pour le vélo mais je
pense que l'argent disponible et voyages
vous l'avez dit mais aussi toutes les
jam était fermé et il restait une chose
des sports individuels en fait pour
pouvoir faire des exercices s'entraîner
donc le vélo la course la marche
donc les gens ils sont effectivement on
a vu beaucoup de genres de nouveau de
nouvelles personnes a fait entrer dans
le sport donc gros arguments au départ
je dirais pour les vélos plus de prix
d'entrée mais comme vous l'avez dit on
été dévalisée complètement à ce niveau
là donc
par la suite je pense les gens qui
avaient des projets pour changer leur
vélo il ya les parents vacances ils ont
regretté leur vélo donc on voit ces gros
marché aussi dans l'usagé par exemple
mais oui c'est vraiment incroyable ce
qui s'est passé au début du col vite on
était un peu pessimiste par rapport à
notre croissance et notre là puisque ça
c'est un mois ça avait 180 degrés oui
mais en même temps c'est pas toujours
évident de faire face à une demande
accrue soudaines comme ça vous vous êtes
adapté de quelle manière
dire qu'on était assez chasse usa après
un petit peu de chance dès fois en
affaires puis un petit peu aval chinese
nous y est on a poussé beaucoup nos
fournisseurs a livré avant d'enchaîner
yeux parce que je n'ai eu une période
qui quand même difficile où
s'approvisionner parce que tout est
fernand nazis puis on a finalement reçu
beaucoup de matériel beaucoup de contenu
de deux vélos et les pièces qui
approprié pour assembler il ya quand
même eu des délais dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement nous on bat si le
cadre ça s'apprend lire ou sapera toute
la race pie xi nous manque une pièce
tarot on peut pas livrer le vélo avec
vous oui
ouais ça on a eu beaucoup de délais dans
la chaîne d'approvisionnement à certains
cas où on vient à peu près de rattraper
le temps au niveau des des vélos qu'on
devait livrer au printemps en boutique
beaucoup de gens qui avaient fait des
pré-réservations ça nous a causé des
problèmes mais les gens ont été patients
les gens ont compris qu'il y avait un
problème de ce traité l'option attendu
patiemment le plus grand fabricant
mondial de vélo james d'une entreprise
de taiwan mais y en a beaucoup des
fabricants québécois je pense à à de
vinci dorel y avouait ce que les
consommateurs ont eu le souci de l'achat
local pour le vélo oui c'est donc on
s'est fait appeler par des détaillants
locaux qui représentent d'autres marques
parce que les gens à leur magasin et les
gens demandaient un produit local
donc on nous on est certains détails
arguant qu' avec lesquels vous
travaillez pas
j'ai travaillé avec d'autres marques et
américaines par exemple qui voulait
avoir des vélos à grands pas ce qu'il ya
eu comme un souci de la clientèle bon
heureusement donc des retombées ici et
là on parlait de tout sauf de vélo ou
palier d'entrée de gamme mais aussi de
l'attrait semble-t-il pour le vélo
électrique qui est là aussi à une plus
forte demande
ça c'est aussi la demande par rapport au
vélo pour aller au travail
c'est déjà votre peau prend des
transports en commun on parle donc tous
les gens veulent voyager à vélo un peu
plus mais voyager à vélo c'est un
distance un peu plus longues à parcourir
cas pas de douche en arrivant au bureau
les gens jettent sur l'électrique pour
enlever la bo de façon un peu pour faire
passer la journée ça d'abord douché par
exemple et ils essaient le camion thing
était un peu réservé aux gens qui
restait sur l'île par exemple de
montréal mais mais si tu restes en
banlieue ben 7 points vélo électrique
pour faire 30 km le matin 30 km seront
donc on voit nagou mal pour le vélo
électrique à la fois du côté des gens
qui veulent aller travailler en vélo
mais aussi beaucoup de gens qui étaient
à la maison qui ont eu le temps de
ressortir faire du vélo est un peu plus
âgé les côtes les distances ne font pas
le vélo électrique
électrique est devenu pour les ce qu'on
appelle en anglais et ce jour pas
l'élément de l'ema qu'ils ont fait
sortir dehors pour pierre refaire du
vélo l'oeil c'est sûr qu'on est dans une
situation un peu particulière c'est le
contexte de pandémie est ce que cet
intérêt marqué pour le vélo c'est
passager ou si là pour durer
on espère que c'est pas fort dur et je
pense que il va alors une courbe qui va
aplatir un peu mais ce qu'on a vu c'est
que beaucoup de nouveaux entrés dans le
sport donc c'est pas juste des ja qui
malgré leur vélo ses plaies de personnes
qui faisait pas de vélo qui ont commencé
à faire du vélo
ces gens là je pense qu' ils ont compris
quelque chose puis avec les années ils
vont changer leur vélo ils vont ils vont
continuer à faire ce sport lucky qui est
fantastique que nous autres détritus de
vélo oui et argon 18 vous êtes en
croissance et je comprends bien monsieur
l'auteur
effectivement on en sort un nouveau vélo
de triathlon puis je revenais la
croissance d'enlever l'autoroute puis le
vélo de grave aussi mais il ya aussi
nous allons on est connu aussi pour nos
vélos de triathlon et puis le triathlon
c'est un autre parent d'avant je dirais
parce que les cours soient pas
recommencer encore donc les gens les
ironman tout ça c est pour partie
et puis ça ça les ventes de vélos tri en
voile on souffre un peu de ce côté là
parce que les gens n'ont pas encore fait
leur plein pour qui je veux faire dans
iron man tram réseau fiable donc ils
sont ils se retiennent peu le pot
l'achat d'un nouveau vélo de triathlon
vous adresser quand même une petite
partie de la population
on doit s'arrêter là dessus je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur l'auteur
merci bonne journée